voilà d'autres ça pétille gervais la
panoz à l'équipage champion de
martinique se doit signal très fort
lancé par l'appétit gerber l'appaloosa
quand c'est le champion de martinique 1
c'est aussi bien le fond me l'avait dit
l'avait dit et répété il y croyait il
avait dit le membre il allait prendre la
tête et leur ambition c'est de gagner le
tour parce qu'ils ont envie de gagner
surtout que le sexuel n'a pas gagné
depuis un moment les victoires est ainsi
très bien mais la victoire du tout c'est
quand même un prestige
voilà je rappelle que la dernière
compétition c'est à dire le taux est
égal et par joseph passe le papa des
fermes à loïc et laurent en 2008 la
dernière victoire finale d'un statut el
menzah dr roots et un surnom à l'époque
c'était en 2008 arrive est donc temps de
ça pétille gerber l'appaloosa avec
vosges auto en plus car ils ont plein
utilise vous allez vraiment ils font une
chose qu'il faut avoir des goûts des
bodys goody bassine petit patio in pace
bassine bois
tout y passe il faut que la grl arrive
au maximum de vitesse sur la ligne la
ligne 2 toutes proches lalime quelques
secondes voilà sur la ligne d'arrivée
20h la yole gervis jab les appétits
l'appaloosa la victoire 2 appétit gerber
l'appaloosa deux victoires de cette
gueule franciscaine et sa 40e victoire
d'étape concernant le placement des
copies en adopteront cette période qui
entame une belle série pour bien
victoire d'étape c'était hier du côté de
voeckler est aujourd'hui inscrite et
deuxième victoire pour les coéquipiers
de loïc masse le patron de sap et hig
le colonel bauer dos et on attend
maintenant la deuxième violent
on s'est passée la ville et dont l'abri
de cette aubaine qui laisser à bâbord
des ans reste sur la ligne d'arrivée
avec l'ambiance
c'est vrai c'était très difficile
le tap difficiles de vent changeant
vente et puis 7 710 c'est cette
inquiétude si vous voulez de le mauvais
temps à bas la météo avec de la pluie
avec tout ce qu'il faut des vins des
vents tournants bon on n'a pas eu ça
aujourd'hui heureusement ça il y avait
quand même c'était quand même de leur
ses voyants avec une étape encore
difficile
il n'y avait pas les couilles il n'y
avait pas l'appui il n'ya pas le vent
tournant pas de dessalage non plus les
mêmes termes à thiès musée mayer ou un
match assez rapidement et qui s'est
remise dans le peloton
voilà il n'y a pas de cas ceux d'il ya
quelques années eco trail j en ferai car
il n'a toujours pas virer la bouée
toujours lui de deux minutes j'ai mon
avis aux 15 2 minutes deux camps sous
l'oeil d'un petit il a éliminé toulouse
oui c'est vrai et éliminer ses
concurrents immédiats et même les autres
qui tient loin des yeux comme cotrel qui
avait quand même peu près de 55 minutes
hier donc si vous mettez les 55 minutes
à dix
or une heure par rapport au premier ce
sera difficile de remonter zapetti qui a
frappé très fort aujourd'hui à utilité
puisque plus de 12 minutes et pour
lequel j'ai enfin n'a toujours pas à
virer la bouée de cette aubaine à
laisser à bâbord la baisse
oh
alizée cas l'ubs a beau vivre là on voit
la yole gerbe les appétits l'appaloosa
qui arrivent ici sur la plage
les supporteurs sont pleinement
satisfaits et les encourage jusqu'au
bout vous pouvez les entendre vous
pouvez peut-être aller voir aussi
l'équipage d'ivo
la foule a crié gerbe les appétits d'un
magasin et rouge c
la winter voilà ils sont leaders ils ont
pris le maillot rouge de leader parce
que les banques fassent antidote d'un
nouveau leader c'est ça péter gerblé
l'appaloosa
à venir l'interview de l'eau y passe le
patron de zapper 10gb l'appaloosa
excellente opération comptable effectué
par cette folle avec des écarts
conséquents et sa petit j'avais la
parité vous voilà à les y attendait
ça tire
à
combien l'action lui cacher
ça bouge beaucoup ici alors
mon personnage est malade la rue lavigne
le mener sur les
déduction lundi matin
elle est bonne
cette victoire
oui avec simon aime parce qu'il ya les
surnomme les pousseurs deuxième victoire
consécutive pour les amplis son équipe à
la malbouffe